This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个由 iHeart 制作的播客。保证由真人录制。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《艰难成长》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）。这个栏目聚焦黑人男性的生活经历，进行那些在其他任何地方都感觉不够安全的坦诚对话，而你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士一起探讨。有多少男人一直穿着一副盔甲。这向世界发出了一个信号：你不是好惹的。这并不意味着你可以这样做，去听听吧。
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
用 AHA 广播应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方，收听《艰难成长》。在 2023 年，单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你曾两次篡改这个特定的测试结果，对吗？我篡改过一次测试结果。网络侦探们费了九牛二虎之力，才揭露了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%.
迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《受困之爱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在 iHeartRadio 应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方，收听《受困之爱》播客。2%。
That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target.
在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，这是选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪现代世界中精神坚韧、体能以及培养复原力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难险阻，你最终就会成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%。》这就是 iHeartRadio 应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方的 TWO.%栏目。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定自己动手。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。
He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody, welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we break
他休想就这样逃脱惩罚。他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。收听播客《闺蜜。相信我，宝贝》（Trust me, babe），可在 iHeartRadio 应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。大家好，欢迎回到《二十岁心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个探讨我们在二十岁时所经历的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好，欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到这个播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你能来到这里，收听又一期节目，我们将剖析
down the psychology of your 20s. It is December, which means it is the guest season of the podcast. And today, we're bringing on someone who has actually been here before, who I'm actually a massive fan of. I would say we're friends. She can, she can. She can. can say what she she can confirm or deny but i feel like if you don't know who list is and her podcast date yourself instead what are you doing she is incredible she is amazing and she is here today to talk about how we can stop getting attached so quickly list thank you so much for coming on again yeah thank you for having me again i'm so excited and i know it's the most cozy time of year and everyone's getting prepared for the holidays i'm very excited to be here
二十岁的心路历程。现在是十二月，这意味着这是播客的嘉宾季。今天，我们请到了一位其实之前来过这里的人，我也真的是她的超级粉丝。我想我们可以算是朋友吧。她可以，她可以。她可以。可以自己说她可以证实或否认，但我感觉如果你不知道莉丝（List）和她的播客《去和你自己约会吧》（Date Yourself Instead），你在干什么呢？她太不可思议了，她太棒了，她今天来到这里，和我们聊聊我们该如何停止那么快付出感情，莉丝，非常感谢你再次来到节目中。对，谢谢你再次邀请我，我太兴奋了，而且我知道这是一年中最温馨的时刻，大家都在为节日做准备，我很高兴能来到这里。
I'm also very jealous that it's actually summer where you are and freezing cold where I am. Yeah, I know. But by the time I'm, by the time this is released, I will be where you are as well. So we can suffer together in the New York winter. Yes, but New York is absolutely amazing during the holiday season. So I'm really excited for you to come. I am as well. I feel like I'm hoping for a white Christmas. Fingers crossed. We'll see what we'll see what it brings. But I feel like if you are listening to this and you have not listened to the first episode we did together, which was like back at the start of the year, pause and go and listen to that first because it is very, very good. But do you want to tell people kind of what you do, the basis for your show? Because I feel like for those of the listeners who are, if you are single right now, if you are someone who is trying to date in your 20s or your 30s,
我也很嫉妒，因为你那里现在其实是夏天，而我这里却冷得要命。对，我懂。不过等我，等这期节目发布的时候，我也会去你所在的地方。这样我们就可以一起在纽约的冬天受苦了。是的，不过纽约在节日期间绝对美极了。所以我真的很为你来这里感到高兴。我也是。我觉得我希望能过一个白色圣诞节。祈祷吧。我们拭目以待，看看会带来什么。但我觉得如果你正在收听这期节目，而且你还没有听过我们一起做的第一期节目，那大约是在今年年初的时候，暂停一下，先去听那一期，因为真的非常非常棒。但是你想不想跟听众讲讲你平时做些什么，以及你的节目主旨是什么？因为我觉得对于那些听众来说，如果你现在是单身，如果你是一个在二十岁或三十岁时尝试约会的人，
or beyond who is struggling with self-worth, with actually investing in yourself and investing in the right people. What do you talk about on your show list? I talk about all things, self-love, healing. If you're going through a breakup, if you're going through a hard time, the reason I created the date yourself instead movement was to really just put the focus back on yourself, especially if you are coming out of a breakup. You can often lose yourself or forget who you were before you met that person and it was inspired by my own breakup. And a lot of the messaging is just centered around knowing yourself, knowing your worth, stepping into your power. And that's why I'm really excited to talk about this particular topic today, all about attachment, because it ties in
或者更年长一些，正在与自我价值感作斗争，在如何真正投资自己以及投资对的人方面感到困惑的人。你在节目中都聊些什么呢，莉丝？我聊所有关于自爱、疗愈的话题。如果你正在经历分手，如果你正在经历艰难时期，我创建“去和你自己约会吧”运动的原因，其实就是为了把重心重新放回你自己身上，特别是如果你刚从一段分手中走出来的话。你往往会迷失自我，或者忘记在遇到那个人之前你是谁，这对我自己的分手也是一种启发。而且很多传达的信息都围绕着了解自己、认识自己的价值、步入自己的力量。这就是为什么我今天很高兴能聊聊这个特定的话题，也就是关于依恋，因为它与
perfectly to pretty much everything I talk about also. I feel like a lot of our episodes overlap. Yeah, especially the dating episodes because I think that when we talk about attachment in our 20s, it is really at the root of a lot of the, I would say, like, love conundrums that we come across, right? The fact that there are some of us out there, like the hopeless romantics, the sentimental, the sensitive, who no matter how hard we try, get attached way too quickly to another person, project this whole like fantasy onto this individual that we might not even know yet. You know, when I was single, I remember like going on, like, like one or two dates with someone and being like, yeah, so like wedding will probably be in June,
我所谈论的几乎所有内容都完美契合。我觉得我们的很多节目都有重叠。对，特别是约会类的话题，因为我认为当我们谈论二十多岁的依恋时，它实际上是许多我想要称之为“爱情谜题”的根源，对吧？事实上，我们当中有些人，比如无可救药的浪漫主义者、多愁善感的人、敏感的人，无论我们多么努力，总是会很快对另一个人产生依恋，把这种完整的幻想投射到这个我们可能还不了解的个体身上。你知道，当我单身的时候，我记得跟某人约会了一两次，然后就会想：“对啊，我们的婚礼大概会在六月举行吧，”
you know, for summer. And like, hopefully he's okay if we call our kids this. And I don't think that it helps you. Like, I don't think it helps you. I don't think it helps the relationship. It makes you so much more invested and more likely to be hurt early on. And it doesn't really let the relationship develop. But I think that we can know all of these things about us, right? Like we can understand that this is our pattern, this is our habit and relationships, this is part of who we are to get attached and not really know what to do about it. So why do you think that we get attached too quickly? Like what are some of the major reasons that you've identified? You know, I'm the type of person who used to get so overly attached and I knew I was getting attached to the wrong person all the time. but it was really out of fear, and I talk about this a lot.
“你知道的，为了夏天。而且，希望他不会介意我们把孩子叫这个名字。”我不认为这会对你有所帮助。我是说，我不认为这帮得了你。我不认为这对这段关系有帮助。这会让你投入更多感情，在早期更容易受到伤害。而且这并没有真正让这段关系顺其自然地发展。但我觉得我们其实都清楚关于我们自身的这些事情，对吧？我们可以理解这就是我们的模式，这是我们在亲密关系中的习惯，产生依恋是我们本性的一部分，却又真的不知道该拿它怎么办。那你觉得为什么我们会这么快产生依恋呢？你所识别出的主要原因有哪些？你知道的，我以前也是那种会过度依恋的人，而且我一直都知道自己依恋错了人。但这其实是出于恐惧，我经常谈到这一点。
Like, when you are alone and you really miss having someone in your life and you miss having a partner and then you meet someone new that has some slight potential, you kind of grasp onto it because you're like, oh, my God, you know, we like the same foods and we had a lot in common on the first date and maybe this could go somewhere and we fantasize and project this fantasy onto that person without really knowing anything about them. if we're coming from a place of fear that we're going to be alone forever. I think you're operating out of fear essentially when you latch yourself onto someone that you don't even know that well or maybe you've only been on a couple of dates and you're like,
比如，当你孤身一人，非常渴望生活中能有个伴侣，非常想念有伴侣的感觉，然后你遇到了一个有着那么一点潜力的、新的人，你就会紧紧抓住不放，因为你会想：“哦，天哪，”你知道的，我们在第一次约会上发现我们喜欢相同的食物，有很多共同点，也许这段感情会有所发展，于是我们在对这个人一无所知的情况下，就开始幻想并把这种幻想投射到他身上。如果我们是出于对永远孤独的恐惧而来。我认为当你把自已系在一个你其实并不那么了解的人身上，或者你们可能只约会了几次，你就觉得：
this is the one when in reality, I mean, sometimes they can be the one. Sometimes it can work out. But oftentimes I just remember getting myself into a lot of situations and even a situation I came out of recently where I saw bits and pieces of potential. and just because I'm alone and I wasn't really seeing anyone else, I latched on to this idea of them that wasn't even real. And I think a lot of people can relate to that. It's like the fantasy bonding, right? You're not falling in love with who this person is in reality. You're falling in love with the version of them that you've created in your head that you are, that is like the perfect
“就是这个人了，”而现实中，我是说，有时他们确实可能是对的人。有时确实能修成正果。但很多时候，我只记得自己曾陷入很多状况中，甚至包括我最近刚走出来的那种状况——我看到了潜力的零星片段，仅仅因为我孤身一人，也没有跟其他人约会，我就紧紧抓住了他们那种根本不是真实的虚构形象。我想很多人都能对此感同身受。这就是幻想绑定，对吧？你爱上的不是这个人在现实中的样子，你爱上的是你在脑海中为他创造的那个版本，那个对你来说是完美
person for you, right? Especially like when you said you're operating from a place of fear, where a lot of us have this intrinsic, I think intrinsic anxiety and worry that we will be alone forever. And maybe part of preventing yourself from getting attached so quickly is understanding that that might not actually be the worst thing in the world. You know, it's not a death, like not finding someone before 30 or before 40 or before 50 does not mean that your life will not have meaning.
伴侣的人，对吧？特别是像你说的，你是出于恐惧而行动，我们中的许多人都有一种内在的、我认为是内在的焦虑和担忧，担心自己会永远孤独。也许，阻止自己过快产生依恋的一部分原因，就是明白那其实可能并不是世界上最糟糕的事情。你知道的，这并非世界末日，在30岁、40岁或50岁之前没有找到另一半，并不意味着你的生活就没有意义。
It doesn't mean that you can. can't still be a very content and happy person. Do you think that that's also part of the fear? Like the fear that to not have a partner means that your life is kind of wasted or that you're missing out on something? Well, I think the feeling of love, if you've gotten a taste of it before, it's something that we're constantly chasing because that high, like when you're first getting to know someone and it actually starts working. If you've been in love before, I think it's easy to want that again and again and kind of, you know, search for it and look for it again and again. And, you know, I think that's a part of the process of everything.
并不意味着你不能。依然可以是一个非常满足和快乐的人。你觉得这也是恐惧的一部分吗？比如，觉得没有伴侣就意味着你的生活某种程度上被浪费了，或者你错过了某些东西？嗯，我觉得爱的感觉，如果你以前曾经体会过，那就是我们一直在追逐的东西，因为那种高潮般的体验——比如当你刚开始了解一个人，而事情真的开始奏效的时候。如果你以前曾经恋爱过，我觉得很容易就会想要一次又一次地体验那种感觉，并且有点像，你知道的，一遍又一遍地去寻找它。而且，我认为这也是一切过程的一部分。
Like I think there's no shame in trying to like seek out those good feelings and seek out those emotions that could make you want to feel like you're in love again. But at the same time, yeah, I think it often comes, like love comes and anything comes in life when you're most grounded in your own frame and you're focused on yourself. and you become more magnetic when you're just centered and you're not actively trying to seek all of these things. And that's why when we were talking about before, like when you met your boyfriend, it's like when you aren't really looking for it and you kind of least expect it, but at the same time, you're open to opportunity. Like, it's not completely closing yourself off
我觉得努力去寻找那些美好的感觉和那些能让你觉得自己仿佛再次恋爱的感情，并没有什么可耻的。但与此同时，是的，我觉得爱情和生活中的任何事情往往都发生在当你最脚踏实地、专注于自我的时候。当你内心笃定、不再积极主动地去刻意寻求所有这些东西时，你会变得更有吸引力。这就是为什么我们之前谈到，就像你遇到你的男朋友时那样，当你并不是真的在寻找它，而且有点始料未及的时候，但同时你对机会又是敞开的。就像，并不是完全把自己封闭起来
from anything. It's just kind of going with the flow and trusting the process. And that's why I always say like trust the process and I have that tattoo because it's kind of like a way to not keep that resistance and you know if you're wanting something too badly it's almost blocking you from actually finding the right person and when you attach yourself to people that aren't good for you you're often kind of blocking what could actually be good for you I 100% agree with that 100% because I think that when you are when you are overlooking parts of someone that you know are not good for you just because you want connection, just because you want intimacy. What you're really doing is kind of abandoning yourself for someone else's gain, right?
拒绝一切可能。这只是一种顺其自然、相信过程的态度。这也是为什么我总是说“相信过程”，我甚至把这句话纹在身上，因为这就像是一种保持不抗拒的方式，你知道的，如果你对某件事的需求过于迫切，它其实会阻碍你真正找到对的人。而当你依恋那些对你不理不睬的人时，你其实往往是在阻挡那些真正对你好的东西。我100%赞同这一点，100%赞同，因为我认为当你
You're abandoning yourself and putting up with someone else's behaviour that you probably wouldn't tolerate from the love of your life. I saw this thing the other day that was like, the love of your life would not treat you the way that you're being treated. So stop confusing, I think, attachment with love or with actual connection. And also, when you're able to identify exactly what you want, exactly who you are, there is this confidence to you that means that you will suddenly attract so many people who are much better options. And people will actually be able to know you as who you are.
忽略了某人某些你明知对你不好的地方，仅仅因为你渴望建立联系，仅仅因为你渴望亲密感。你真正做的是为了别人的利益而抛弃了你自己，对吧？你抛弃了自己，去容忍别人那些你可能绝不会从你一生的挚爱身上容忍的行为。我前几天看到一句话，大意是：你一生的挚爱绝不会像你现在这样对待你。所以别再把依恋与爱或真正的连接混为一谈了。另外，当你能够准确识别出自己想要什么、自己究竟是谁时，你就会散发出一种自信，这意味着你突然会吸引到更多、更好的选择。而且人们也才能真正认识真实的你。
And I think knowing yourself for who you are means that that unconditional love that we expect from others is going to be true, right? It's not going to be based on a fantasy they have of you either or a fantasy that you have of them because you're really like centered and grounded in your own reality and in your own expectations and in your own sense of self. Yeah, for sure. And I think it's easier said than done too because there's a lot of times where, you know, I create these boundaries for myself and I create really high standards for myself in my head. And sometimes if you just tell yourself, yeah, like, I'm not going to tolerate this. I'm not going to tolerate that. It's not really that effective because words are words, you really have to feel it and believe
我认为了解真正的自己，意味着我们对他人抱有的那种无条件的爱将会成真，对吧？它不会建立在他们对你的幻想之上，也不会建立在你对他们的幻想之上，因为你真的立足于现实，扎根于自己的期望和自我意识之中。是的，确实如此。而且我认为这也说起来容易做起来难，因为很多时候，你知道的，我为自己设立了界限，并在脑海中为自己设定了很高的标准。有时如果你只是告诉自己：“对啊，我不会容忍这个的。我不会容忍那个的。”这其实并不是那么有效，因为语言只是语言，你必须真正去感受它并坚信它。
it. You know, you really have to be in a place in your life where you're actually grounded and you actually have worked on yourself a lot and healed so many parts of yourself that you know that you will not settle for anything less than what you deserve. And I was humbled recently from a situation where, you know, and I'm going to talk about this on my own podcast at some point, but like I'll say it on here also. I was in a situation recently where I got attached to this idea of the potential of what something could be with a person that kept convincing me that he was going to change. And any time I would bring something up, you know, I would see bits and pieces of potential where he was treating me right at certain points. And he was doing and saying the right things at certain points.
你知道的，你必须处于生活中的这样一个阶段：你真正脚踏实地，真正对自己进行了很多内在修复，治愈了自己内心的许多部分，以至于你知道你绝不会将就，只会接受配得上你的一切。我最近因为一种情况而变得谦卑了，你知道的（我以后会在自己的播客里聊这个，但现在我也在这里说吧）。我最近陷入了一种情况，我依恋上了“某种可能性”的概念——和一个不断说服我他会改变的人在一起的可能性。每当我提起什么事情时，你知道的，我总能看到潜力的零星片段，比如他在某些时候确实以正确的方式对待我。他在某些时候做了正确的事，也说了正确的话。
But there were so many other problems and I would overlook it because I got attached to the fantasy. And it's such a common thing because when you want to see the good in people and when you want love and you are a loving person, it's easy to latch on. And there's no shame in it. But it's there to teach you a valuable lesson about, you know, really putting all that energy into yourself versus externally throwing it at someone else that doesn't deserve it. And I think I learned that through a lot of my situationships and relationships in general. So, yeah. But you get to like a good point where it's like these relationships are not a waste, right? Like they are teaching you something.
但还有很多其他的问题，而我却选择视而不见，因为我依恋上了那种幻想。这是太常见不过的事情了，因为当你想要看到人们好的一面，当你渴望爱，而你又是一个充满爱心的人时，你就很容易沦陷。这没什么好羞耻的。但这正是为了给你上一课，让你明白应该把所有的能量都投入到自己身上，而不是向外倾注在一个不值得的人身上。我想我是通过自己的许多“暧昧关系”（situationship）和一般的恋爱关系才学到这一点的。所以，是的。但你会达到一个很好的节点，那就是这些关系并不是在浪费时间，对吧？它们是在教给你一些东西。
I used to be like every person who breaks my heart, every person where it doesn't work is just one step closer to someone who will. And if you poured all of that love and all of that energy and that intimacy and that time into the wrong person, imagine how amazing it's going to be when it's with the right person. Like imagine how, like, it's just going to be, and I know this to be true. Like, it's insane and it's the best feeling when the love that you've always shown people that's never been reciprocated is finally reciprocated. And you realize what true attachment and true connection and true compatibility actually feels like rather than getting caught up in the intensity, in the fantasy, in like the anxiety
我以前觉得，每一个伤我心的人，每一个没有结果的人，都只是让我离那个对的人更近了一步。如果你把所有的爱、所有的能量、所有的亲密感和时间都倾注在了错误的人身上，想象一下，当这一切属于那个正确的人时，会有多美妙。想象一下，那将是，这绝对是真的。当那些你一直给予他人却从未得到回报的爱终于得到回报时，那种感觉简直疯狂，而且是无与伦比的美妙。你终于明白真正的依恋、真正的连接和真正的契合感是什么感觉了，而不是再陷入那种强烈的情感、幻想以及
of pursuing someone who doesn't want you back. Because I also think that sometimes we confuse a lot of that anxiety with excitement and with chemistry. I don't know if you do this, but I think that it's just they feel very similar in our bodies. And so we confuse the sensations and that creates this very instantaneous attachment. Yeah. I mean, I think my rule now with my emotions is if I'm at all uncomfortable, anxious and worried within the first few dates, it's a hard no. Like your gut will tell you almost instantly if it's not going to work. And well, at least for me, I truly believe that.
追求一个不爱你的人所带来的焦虑之中。因为我也觉得，有时我们会把很多那种焦虑误认为是兴奋和化学反应。我不知道你是不是这样，但我觉得它们在我们的身体里感觉太相似了。所以我们混淆了这些感觉，从而产生了这种瞬间的依恋。是的。我的意思是，我现在对自己的情感设定的原则是：如果在前几次约会中我有哪怕一点点的不舒服、焦虑和担忧，那绝对是想都别想，直接拒绝。你的直觉几乎能立刻告诉你这行不行得通。嗯，至少对我来说，我坚信这一点。
And I did this survey on my Instagram a while ago that was asking people who were in serious relationships or married, how they knew their person was the one and they weren't just getting, you know, attached to some random person. And almost every response said, I felt a sense of peace and calm. Like I had never experienced before where I felt safe. My nervous system felt at peace and at ease. And it was something that I didn't know existed. And I was like shocked.
我前段时间在 Instagram 上做了一个调查，问那些处于稳定恋爱关系或已婚的人，他们是怎么知道对方就是对的人，而不是仅仅对某个随便的人产生依恋的。几乎每一个回答都是：我感受到了一种前所未有的平和与平静，我感到很安全。我的神经系统感到了平和与放松。那是我以前甚至不知道存在的一种感觉。我当时震惊了。
Like so many people had the same answer. And I was really thinking about it. I'm like, I don't know if I've ever actually experienced that. And that's something that I'm looking forward to now because we tend to get attached to people that make us anxious, especially if we're anxious attached people. Like I have anxious attachment style. I don't know about you. But I'm an anxious attached person.
那么多人都给出了同样的答案。我真的在思考这件事。我想：“我不知道自己是否真的曾体验过那种感觉。”这也是我现在所期待的，因为我们往往会依恋那些让我们感到焦虑的人，特别是如果我们本身就是焦虑型依恋的人的话。比如我就是焦虑型依恋风格。我不知道你是不是。但我是一个焦虑型依恋的人。
So it's kind of easier to spot when something's not working for me early on now. And I know that I need to detach myself and remove from the situation quickly. That's actually such a good point. Like I'm going to say I feel that way now where everyone used to always say to me, love is meant to be easy. and it's meant to be calm and it's meant to be peaceful. And I was like, that sounds really boring. I really honestly thought that. I was like, that sounds boring.
所以现在我能更容易地在早期发现什么时候事情对我不管用了。我知道我需要让自己脱离并迅速抽身离开。这真的是个很好的观点。我可以说我现在就是这种感觉，过去每个人都总是对我说：“爱情本该是轻松的，”
I'm used to like the spark. I'm used to like this intense passion that is so self-destructive and will burn out your relationship. And I think sometimes we meet those people, right, who could be the one, who could really fulfill us. But we sabotage the relationship because we have gotten so used to this. of people who have made us feel a certain way, that we don't really trust our first impression.
“它本该是平静的，本该是安稳的。”而我的反应是：“听起来好无聊啊。”我当时真的是这么想的。我觉得：“听起来真无聊。”我习惯了那种火花。我习惯了那种极具破坏性、会燃尽你们关系的强烈激情。而且我觉得有时候我们确实会遇到那些人，对吧，那些可能是对的人，那些真正能成就我们的人。但我们却亲手破坏了这段关系，因为我们已经习惯了
We see someone as boring. We might see someone as not really our type. Because we are expecting this like firework of feelings when really what you should be looking for is the person who, of course, you have so much fun with and who sees you and who you're excited by, but who also at the end of the day does not leave you questioning whether they actually want to be with you. And if you were to, like, it's the, you should not be sitting there being like, does this person actually like me? The moment that you are asking yourself that question, A, the answer is no, B, the second part of that is you need to run. Like, you need to cut that person out because I think that, like, I don't know if you've had that experience, but I'm like, that is no good sign for the start of a relationship. Oh, yeah.
那些让我们产生特定感觉的人，以至于我们不再真正相信自己的第一印象。我们会觉得某个人很无聊。我们可能会觉得某个人其实不是我们的菜。因为我们期待着烟花般绚烂的情感，而实际上你该寻找的应该是这样一个人：当然，和他在一起你会有很多乐趣，他能懂你，能让你感到兴奋，但在一天结束时，他不会让你去质疑他是否真的想和你在一起。如果你坐在那里想着：
Well, the experience I just recently went through with someone, it was dragged out for five full months. And five months. Five months of my time. I mean, listen, a lot of the time I wasn't physically together with him. Like, we live in different countries. I barely saw him throughout those five months. But it was a lot of texting, communication, whatever. And it's still energy.
“这个人真的喜欢我吗？”当你问出那个问题的那一秒，A，答案是否定的；B，接下来的第二部分是：你需要快跑。你需要断绝和这个人的联系，因为我觉得，我不知道你是否有过这种经历，但我会觉得：这对于一段关系的开始来说绝对不是什么好兆头。哦，对。好吧，我最近经历的那段关系，被生生拖了整整五个月。整整五个月。五个月的时间。我是说，听着，很多时候我并没有和他朝夕相处。比如，我们住在不同的国家。在这五个月里我几乎见不到他。但有大量的短信、沟通等等。那依然是能量消耗。
You know, it's still your time and it's still your feelings at play and it's still your emotions. So, you know, I always say, like, your time and your energy towards someone is your currency. and it's really true because I started getting a little too invested and I would try to make shit work all the time with him where it was like I was like okay um you know I'm here you're there what's going on like do you want to talk whatever and he would just always find a way to make it difficult right and then once I pulled back he would try to get me reattached you know it was one of those games where it was like I would kind of detach myself and remove and say, you know what, F this, I'm out. And he would be like, oh, no, talk to me. I want to talk through
你知道的，那依然消耗着你的时间，消耗着你的感受，也消耗着你的情绪。所以，你知道的，我总是说，你对某个人投入的时间和精力就是你的货币。这真的很真实，因为我开始变得有点过于投入，我总是试图去勉强维持和他的关系，我会觉得：“好吧，”
it. What's going on? And manipulate me back into the situation. I think that's why a lot of people hold on. And that's why I'm bringing it up right now because maybe it could help someone. Like, you know, people will find a way to keep you holding on even if they don't want you. And it has to be up to you to cut the court and walk away. And eventually, I did. And I cut the court and I said, you know, this is my life. This is my feelings. This is like, you know, my energy and my time. And if you're not valuing that and you're playing this game with me where you just want me around, but you're not actually going to see any sort of future with me, what the hell am I doing? You know, so I think a lot of people could probably relate to that situation because people will want you to be attached to them. People will
“嗯，我在这一头，你在那一头，到底怎么了？你想聊聊吗，诸如此类。”而他总是能找到方法把事情弄得很艰难，对吧？然后一旦我抽身退后，他又会试图让我重新产生依恋，你知道的，这就是那种心理游戏——当我试图抽离并离开，说：“你知道吗，去他的，我不干了。”他就会说：“哦，不，跟我聊聊。我想谈谈。”“怎么了？”然后又把我操纵回那种状况中。我想这就是为什么很多人死死不放手的原因。这也是为什么我现在要把它提出来，因为也许这能帮到某个人。你看，人们总会找到办法让你死死抓着不放，即便他们并不真正想要你。而必须由你来亲手斩断情丝、扬长而去。最终，我真的这么做了。我斩断了情丝，说道：“你知道吗，这是我的生活。这是我的感受。这代表了我的时间和精力。”如果你不珍视这些，却和我玩这种心理游戏——只是想让我在你身边，却压根没打算和我有什么未来，那我到底在干什么呢？所以，我想很多人都能对这种处境感同身受，因为人们会希望你依恋他们，人们会
want you to hold on to them and they'll feed you this idea that maybe it could work. And it's so relatable. And, you know, even someone who has a dating podcast, like I literally talk about this and give advice about this, it is easier said than done when you're in a situation where there's a connection. So, you know, but you learn from it. And I'm like, I feel like it's made me even better and stronger and I'm like happy. And it's all good.
希望你紧抓着他们不放，并给你灌输“也许我们还有可能”的想法。这太容易让人共鸣了。而且，你知道的，甚至连一个拥有约会播客的人——我每天都在谈论这个并给出建议——当你在一段确实有连接的状况中时，也是说起来容易做起来难。所以，你知道的，但你会从中吸取教训。我觉得这反而让我变得更好、更强大了，我很开心。一切都挺好的。
But it's, uh, it's, it's very common. It's this thing, right, where it's not that that person didn't know what he had. He was very aware of what he had. That is why he was constantly trying to bring you back in. Maybe he was obsessed with the chase. That made him feel like it was worth it. He knew what he had. He just didn't know what to do with it.
但它，呃，这非常普遍。就是这种现象，对吧？并不是说那个人不知道他拥有什么。他非常清楚自己拥有什么。正因如此，他才不断地试图把你拉回他的世界。也许他沉迷于追求的过程。这让他觉得一切都是值得的。他知道自己拥有什么。他只是不知道该怎么对待它。
And he didn't want to treat you in the way that you deserved, right? I think that sometimes when we encounter these people who, aren't willing to commit or who act in the way that this man was acting trash man. That's such terrible behavior. But when we meet people who act in that way, we think that for them to fully want us would be the biggest, biggest sign to us that we are worth something. And so it's not just about attachment. It's also about our sense of self-esteem.
而且他不想以你应得的方式对待你，对吧？我认为有时候当我们遇到这些人时，他们不愿意承诺，或者表现得像这个男人那样——简直是个垃圾人。这行为太糟糕了。但当我们遇到这样的人时，我们会认为他们完全想要我们，将是我们证明自己有价值的最大、最大的信号。所以这不仅关乎依恋。这也关乎我们的自尊感。
And it's about our sense of self-value and our sense of value as a person where we think okay well if this person doesn't want me if this person isn't willing to treat me the way that I deserve what does that say about me and so you become obsessed with almost winning them over or proving to them that they should change or they should treat you differently because that kind of journey that kind of convincing is a proxy for you trying to convince yourself that you have value if this person believes it, you can finally believe it. And there are people out there who unfortunately understand that and understand that they can have that impact on people and who use it. And I think, I know that you and I are both very, like, romantic and sensitive people.
这关乎我们的自我价值感和作为一个人的人格价值，我们会想：好吧，如果这个人不想要我，如果这个人不愿意以我应得的方式对待我，那这说明了什么关于我的问题？于是你开始变得痴迷于赢得他们的认可，或者向他们证明他们应该改变、他们应该以不同的方式对待你，因为那种旅程、那种说服的过程，其实是你试图说服自己你是有价值的代用品——如果这个人相信这一点，你终于就能相信了。不幸的是，世界上确实有些人明白这一点，他们知道自己能对别人产生这种影响力并加以利用。而且我知道你和我都是非常浪漫和敏感的人。
I think that's, like, a brilliant, brilliant thing. But do you think that also is one of the reasons why people get attached a little bit too quickly? I think if you're a very loving person and you're very vulnerable and you're sensitive as a person. And, you know, a lot of women are. I mean, a lot of people are. I'm not going to just pin it on women. A lot of people in general are. But I think for me, I'm just speaking from my experience.
我觉得这是一种非常、非常棒的特质。但你觉得这也是人们稍微有点太快产生依恋的原因之一吗？如果你是一个非常充满爱心的人，在感情上非常脆弱且敏感的话。你知道的，很多女性都是这样。我是说，很多人都是这样。我可不只是把这归咎于女性。总体而言很多人都是这样。但对我而言，我只是在说我自己的经历。
I think I have a hard, you know, shell maybe, but I'm really soft. And I try to give people as many chances as I can because I just, you know, and you're the same way probably you just want to see the good in people because we're good people. And a lot of people are like that where they're good people and they want to believe that the other person on the other end of their situation, ship or relationship is the same way that they are. But that's really not often the case. You know, when you're in a situation where you're latching onto someone and they know what they have and they're not able to value it, but they still want to keep you around. I think it's easy for sensitive people who love very deeply to get taken advantage of.
我觉得我可能有一层坚硬的外壳，但内心其实非常柔软。我会尽量给别人尽可能多的机会，因为我只是，而且你可能也是这样——你只是想看到人性好的一面，因为我们本身就是善良的人。很多人都是这样，他们是善良的人，并且愿意相信他们的暧昧对象或恋爱对象的另一端也和他们是一样的人。但现实往往并非如此。你知道的，当你陷入这样一种状况：你紧紧抓住某人不放，而他们明明知道自己拥有什么却不懂得珍惜，却还想把你留在身边。对于那些爱得很深沉的敏感之人来说，我觉得确实很容易被利用。
I do, unfortunately. But I also think, as you mentioned earlier, about knowing your worth and having a really good self concept of yourself, that's the key to attracting better people into your life. And I think a lot of why we attach ourselves to people is also related to low self-esteem. And I'm not going to lie. I tend to get insecure, especially when it comes to love. I tend to nitpick myself internally. And that's something I'm working on now. And it's something I've been working on for a while where I want to wake up every day feeling so insanely confident that I know 100% what I have to offer all the time.
确实如此，不幸的是。但我也像你刚才提到的那样，关于了解自己的价值并对自我有一个极好的概念，这才是吸引更好的人进入你生活 Κ 的关键。而且我认为我们之所以依恋别人，很大程度上也与低自尊有关。我也不撒谎。我往往会感到不安全感，特别是在涉及爱情的时候。我往往会在内心对百般挑剔。这也是我现在正在努力克服的事情，而且我已经为此努力了一段时间——我想要每天醒来时都感到无比自信，100% 清楚自己随时能够提供什么。
But there's a lot of people in my past who have chiseled away at that version of me that I want to be. So if I'm like, you know, I'm amazing, I'm beautiful, I'm the best. I've had a lot of guys try to like break that down. And because I'm sensitive and I let them in, it's affected me, you know, where they say, oh, you know, go put on makeup. Or like, I've had guys tell me that. Or like, sorry, I'm not like laughing because it's funny. I'm laughing because it's absolutely insane. Or like.
但在我的过去，有许多人不断消磨着我想要成为的那个版本的自己。所以如果我说：“你知道的，我很棒，我很漂亮，我是最好的。”有很多男人试图打破这种自信。而且因为我很敏感，我让他们走进了我的生活，这确实对我产生了影响，你知道的，他们会说：“哦，你知道的，去化个妆吧。”或者，有些男人真的对我说过这样的话。或者，抱歉，我笑不是因为这很好笑。我笑是因为这简直太疯狂了。或者像。
Shock. Yeah. Or like, you know, I've had guys comment on my weight. before like I don't know why they just have and I'm like okay this is making me uncomfortable or I've had guys tell me I'm not worth a certain you know amount of money or like if they take me out they expect me to pay for everything things like that where it's made me feel like garbage because I'm like okay am I not worth like a five dollar coffee so you know it's just about learning how to build yourself up again and have that like unbreakable unshakable self-
太震惊了。对啊。或者你知道的，有些男人的评论过我的体重。以前有过，我不知道为什么，他们就是会这样，而我会觉得：这让我很不舒服。或者有些男人告诉我，我不值某个特定数额的钱，或者如果他们带我出去，他们希望我支付所有费用，诸如此类的事情让我觉得自己就像垃圾一样，因为我会想：好吧，难道我不值一杯五块钱的咖啡吗？所以，这其实就是关于学会如何重新建立自我，拥有那种坚不可摧、不可动摇的自-
self-confidence and then you'll probably attract better people into your life. I also think that those experiences, right? It's so hard when it's so unfair. It's not just hard. It's unfair when you have to undo the damage that someone else has done. Where someone has like come into your heart, come into your soul, come into your life, and then like, I'm going to make a mess of this just for fun. Like I'm going to chisel down this person's confidence.
自信，然后你大概就会吸引更好的人走进你的生活。我也觉得那些经历，对吧？当你不得不去弥补别人造成的伤害时，那种感觉不仅艰难，而且很不公平。这不仅仅是艰难。当你不得不去修复别人对你造成的破坏时，那太不公平了。有人走进了你的心，走进了你的灵魂，走进了你的生活，然后说：“我要把这一切弄得一团糟，就为了好玩。”“我要一点点凿掉这个人的自信。”
I think because they understand that then you're more reliant on them for your confidence so they have more control of you. Maybe they don't realize it. Maybe you don't realize it. But I think that I've seen that in my own life so many times. And it's just, it is unfair to be like, okay, well, now this experience is a part of me. And it's not something that I'm ever going to forget. It's not something that I'm not going to think of of time to time. But I do think that your point of like, you need to become almost like this, you need to become this like impenetrable kind of fortress of like self-love and self-worth and confidence where you're like your opinion of me, how you choose to treat me has absolutely nothing to do with who I am.
我想是因为他们明白，那样的话你就会更依赖他们来获得自信，于是他们就对你拥有了更多控制权。也许他们自己没意识到。也许你也没意识到。但我认为我在自己的生活中已经看到过无数次这种情况了。这真的，经历过这些并心想：“好吧，现在这段经历已经成了我的一部分，而且这不是我能轻易忘记的，也不是我不会偶尔想起的。”但我确实认为你的观点很对——你几乎需要变成这样一个人，你需要变成一座刀枪不入的、由自爱、自尊和自信筑成的堡垒，让你觉得：你对我的看法、你选择如何对待我和我是谁完全没有半点关系。
Because when you think about it, there are millions of people out there who sometimes we don't, we don't give them a chance or we just haven't met them yet, who would treat you amazingly. it's this like it's this metaphor of like your worth stays the same it's just how much someone else values it and what kind of price you're willing to take like I saw this analogy that was like
因为仔细想想，外面有数百万的人——有时我们只是没给他们机会，或者还没遇到他们——他们会待你如珠如宝。这就像是一个隐喻——你的价值始终如一，只是别人对你的估价不同，以及你愿意接受什么样的筹码——我之前看到过这样一个比喻：
a bottle of water you know at the grocery store is like is a dollar a bottle of water at like the airport is like six dollars like a bottle of water at like a concert is like $12 like the water remains the same like it's the same product but it's where you're valued, it's where there is demand for the kind of person that you are.
杂货店里的一瓶水，你知道的，卖一美元；机场里的一瓶水大概要六美元；音乐会上一瓶水大概要12美元。水本身依然是一样的——它还是那个产品，但它所处的位置决定了它的价值，决定了对你这种人的需求在哪里。
And I think some part of us, when we have gone through a lot of dating experiences, where we have been rejected, shut down, we have fallen into this pattern of looking for the same kind of people, we really forget that. And we forget that there are actually so many people out there who would value us for who we are. So what are some of the signs of someone who is worth emotionally attached? to who is worth that effort and who you think is like I know with this whole episode is like how do I not get attached too quickly sometimes though there are people who you have a gut instinct to write for you like what are some of the distinctions do you think between the people you
我想我们内心深处的一部分，当我们经历了很多约会经历、遭遇拒绝、受到打击、陷入追求同一类人的模式时，我们真的会把这些忘得精光。我们忘记了其实外面有那么多会因为你是谁而珍视你的人。那么，对于一个值得你投入情感依恋的人，一个值得你付出努力、而且你认为——我知道这一整集的重点是如何做到不过快产生依恋，但有时确实有些人会让你产生直觉上的对的感觉——你认为那些绝对应该避开的人和那些你愿意向其展露更多脆弱的人之间，有哪些区别呢？哦，我认为是那种在早期就能理解你的情绪、你不需要解释自己的人。一切都很轻松，你知道的，一切都是顺其自然的。沟通很顺畅。
should absolutely avoid and the people who you should kind of be willing to be more vulnerable with oh I think someone who understands your emotions early on you don't have to explain yourself. It's just easy, you know, it just flows. The communication that is there. They understand who you are and what you're about early on in the relationship where they can, you know, kind of understand your needs and respect them and respect your boundaries. I think respect and having a mutual respect early on for one another is such a green flag and, you know, consistency. I think a really big thing for me personally what I've seen and the people that I've ended up in serious relationships with is they were always consistent they knew exactly what they wanted and they were like it's you
他们在关系的早期就能理解你是谁、你在追求什么，从而能够（你知道的）理解你的需求并尊重它们，尊重你的界限。我认为尊重以及在早期对彼此产生相互尊重是一个巨大的绿旗，而且（你知道的）保持一致性。我认为对我个人而言，我所看到的以及我最终与之建立严肃关系的人身上有一个非常重要的共同点：他们始终如一，他们确切地知道自己想要什么，并且会说：“就是你，”
you know it's you you're the one and I want to date you and everyone deserves that everyone deserves that feeling of being wanted and there's nothing wrong with wanting that feeling of being wanted but you know I think we often try to convince ourselves out of things that we try to convince ourselves of things that are maybe not necessarily good for us, we try to justify why things can change all the time. And we try to make up stories in our head and fantasize like, oh, you know, maybe once he's done with work, you know, he said work's busy for the next two months. Maybe things will get better after that. Or, you know, I've heard that excuse many times. Oh, I'm busy with work and, you know, I'm not really looking for a relationship at this time,
你知道的，“就是你，你就是那个人，我想和你约会。”每个人都配得上这种感觉，每个人都配得上那种被渴望的感觉，渴望这种感觉并没有错。但是，你知道的，我认为我们经常试图说服自己去放弃某些事情，我们试图说服自己去接受那些或许对我们不一定有益的事情，我们总是在为事情为什么会改变寻找合理化借口。我们试图在脑海中编造故事并进行幻想，比如：“哦，你知道的，也许等他忙完工作，”他说接下来两个月工作很忙。“也许在那之后情况会变好。”或者，“我听过很多次这种借口了：‘哦，我很忙，而且我目前确实没有在找恋爱关系，’”
but I will be. It's a very common excuse. Or like, You know, just things like that where no one's making excuses about wanting to be with you or see you. Someone who can make a plan and want to see you and want to be around you because if you like someone, you're going to want to spend time with them. That's just a natural human instinct. Those are all green flags to me where I'm like, yes, okay, you want to see me. You want to talk to me. Everything feels emotionally safe. Huge, for me, at least, indicators that it's moving in the right direction.
“但我以后会找的。”这是一个非常普遍的借口。或者像：你知道的，类似这样的话——没有人会为想要和你在一起或想要见你而找借口。一个真正喜欢你的人，会想要花时间和你在一起。这只是一种人类的自然本能。对我来说，所有这些都是绿旗，我会觉得：“太好了，好吧，你想见我。你想和我说话。一切都让我感到情感上的安全。”对我而言，至少这是朝着正确方向发展的巨大标志。
What about you? Well, I actually was listening to that being like, yeah, I completely agree 100%. One other one I would say, which I think actually links to what you were talking about is they don't just want you on their terms. Because I think that that example that you gave of, oh, works really busy. I don't want to date you. But also, yeah, please come over five nights a week and, like, come and hang out with me. It's like, that is them giving, that is them basically being like, I want you on my. my terms. I want you when it's convenient for me. I don't care about you. I don't care about what you need
你呢？嗯，其实我听完就在想，对，我百分之百完全同意。我还想说的一点，我觉得这其实跟你刚才说的有关，那就是他们不只是想按他们的条件来接受你。因为我觉得你刚才举的那个例子，哦，工作好忙，我不想跟你约会。但同时呢，又，好啦，请你一周来我家过夜五次，然后，来陪我。这就好像，那是他们在付出，那是他们基本上在说，我想要你按照我。我的条件来。我只在方便的时候需要你。我不在乎你。我不在乎你需要什么
for me. Yeah, it's like, it's so common. I think especially like in guys who are like 20, like early 30s, where I get it, right? Like it's not, it might not be a huge priority for them. But there are people out there who it would be a priority, who seeing you would be a priority, who spending time with you would be a priority and it wouldn't just be based on like what their schedule looks like and it wouldn't just be based on like how their life is going right now they would make space for you to be there and then I also think the other thing is being really clear about the future there is no like oh yeah ambiguity around the fact that you are in their future with them so then being like oh you know even as small as being like oh next week we should um go
对我来说。嗯，这就像，这太常见了。我觉得特别是像20多岁到30岁出头的男生，我能理解，对吧？就像它不是，对他们来说这可能不是什么大不了的优先事项。但确实有些人会把这当作优先事项，把见你当作优先事项，把花时间陪你当作优先事项，而不是仅仅根据他们的日程安排来决定，也不仅仅根据他们目前的生活状况来决定，他们会为你腾出空间让你参与其中，然后我还觉得另一件事是，对未来要非常清晰。不会有那种，哦，对于你存在于他们的未来之中这件事有任何的含糊不清。所以他们就会觉得，哦，你知道，甚至哪怕是很小的事情，比如“哦，我们下周应该呃去
to this museum or I really want to go to this restaurant, we should go. Or being like, I think I'm going to go. Yeah, like, hey, like, you know, Christmas, I'm going to go see my parents. Like, what are you doing for Christmas? Like, there is a sense of like continuity there. It's not, and I think that's really important, especially if you are someone who is anxious because you're not constantly trying to anticipate when the relationship is going to end. This person, oh my God, I love that. Yeah, but they have, like, it's true, right? Like they have enough respect for you to make you feel comfortable that the relationship is going somewhere. Yeah, 100%. Like I remember when I got into my last relationship, I was shocked by how forward and how much effort he was making. And I was like, wait, this is normal.
这个博物馆”或者“我真的很想去这家餐厅，我们应该去。”或者觉得，“我想我要去。”对，就像，嘿，就像，你知道，圣诞节，我要去见我父母。你会怎么过圣诞节？就像，那里有一种连贯性的感觉。它不是，而且我觉得这真的很重要，特别是如果你是一个容易焦虑的人，因为你不会一直在猜测这段感情什么时候会结束。这个人，哦天哪，我太喜欢这个了。对，但他们有，确实如此，对吧？就像他们对你有足够的尊重，让你感到安心，觉得这段感情是有发展前景的。对，百分之百。就像我记得当我进入上一段感情时，我被他那种直白以及他付出的巨大努力给震惊了。然后我就想，等等，这是正常的吗？
Like, this is what normal is. I don't have to decipher what he's trying to say and question if he likes me. He was literally from the beginning, he was like, I want to hang out with you. I want to take you to dinner. I want to see you. And he was constantly following up about plans and making an effort so, like so many times. And I was the one blowing him off. You know, like I was the one saying, I'm busy.
就像，这才是正常的样子。我不需要去猜测他到底想表达什么，也不用怀疑他是不是喜欢我。他从一开始就直截了当地说，我想跟你一起出去。我想带你去吃晚餐。我想见你。而且他一直在跟进计划并为此努力，所以，真的很多次。而反而是我在放他鸽子。你知道的，就像我是那个说“我很忙”的人。
I have plans. Because I was scared. I was like, what is this? Like, is this man mentally stable? Like I thought he was the problem at first because I had never experienced what it's like to actually be wanted in a healthy way, which is crazy. which is crazy to think about. I mean, I did have other boyfriends before
我有安排。因为我感到害怕。我当时就在想，这是什么情况？这个男人精神正常吗？我一开始还以为是他的问题，因为我从来没有体验过真正以健康的方式被人渴望是什么感觉，这太疯狂了。回想起来真是太疯狂了。我的意思是，我以前确实也有过别的男朋友，
that were pretty straightforward, but there was a little more effort involved. But with him, it was just, it was so forward and it was so easy. And I learned so much from that relationship because he always knew what he wanted. And it was, it was like too easy. It just felt so good.
他们也挺直爽的，但需要付出更多一点的努力。但跟他在一起时，完全就是，非常直接，而且一切都水到渠成。我从那段感情中学到了很多，因为他总是很清楚自己想要什么。而且，这简直太轻松了。感觉实在是太美妙了。
And I remember he would always include me in his plans. He would always make me a part of his life. He would say, do you want to meet my friends? Do you want to come to my party that I'm having with the people that I know? You know, he always made me a part of his circle from the beginning. And that's how I knew it was different. I knew it was different right away because I was like, he wants me to meet his friends on day two?
我记得他总是把我也纳入他的计划中。他总是让我成为他生活的一部分。他会说，你想见见我的朋友吗？你想来参加我和我认识的人办的派对吗？你知道的，从一开始他就让我融入了他的社交圈。我就是这样知道这段感情与众不同的。我马上就知道它不一样了，因为我想，他第二天就想让我见他的朋友？
Like, what's happening right now? I think a lot of people, I want to say men, some people get annoyed like saying like men and women, whatever. But I really do believe, like if we're talking from a male perspective, they kind of know instantly if they want to be with you. And maybe that's not the best. You know, obviously I know it doesn't apply to every relationship because every relationship has a different course. But I truly believe, for the most part, a man kind of knows what he wants within the first couple of dates.
天哪，现在是什么情况？我觉得很多人，我想说是男人，有些人会觉得烦，说什么男人和女人之类的话。但我真的相信，如果我们从男性的角度来看，他们其实瞬间就能知道自己是不是想跟你在一起。也许这并不是最好的。你知道的，我当然知道这并不适用于每一段感情，因为每段感情的发展轨迹都不同。但我真心相信，在大多数情况下，一个男人在前几次约会内就基本上知道自己想要什么了。
I also think that men in particular do not face the same societal pressure that women do to settle. So I think that that's something that we can take, right? It's something that we can take from them. That's why they know instantly. that's why they know whether they like someone or not is because they are not also trying to navigate. Well, I'm like, they're also not trying to navigate the sense of like, oh, you know, better find someone by 30. Like my biological clock is ticking or I don't want to be a spinster or I don't want to end up alone or all my friends are in relationships. Like women have been so indoctrinated by society and have learned so much about how they deserve to be trained.
我也觉得特别是男性不会像女性那样面临相同的社会压力去“将就”。所以我觉得这是我们可以借鉴的，对吧？这是我们可以从他们身上学到的东西。这就是为什么他们能瞬间知道。这就是为什么他们知道自己是否喜欢一个人，因为他们不需要同时去应付。嗯，就像，他们也不需要去应付那种感觉，哦，你知道，最好在30岁之前找到人。就像我的生物钟在滴答作响，或者我不想成为老处女，或者我不想孤独终老，或者我所有的朋友都在谈恋爱。女性已经被社会严重洗脑了，并且从中学到了太多关于她们应该如何被对待的观念，
from like almost a deficit mindset where the thing that you need most is a relationship, whereas for men, the thing that they need most is like career success or like financial stability. And as much as we think that like that has changed, there is still, that is still very implicit in how we are raised. It's very implicit in the world we see around us. So I think that's why men are so much better able to make those kind of judgment calls. Also, I love that, he like introduced you to his friends. I always say they should be treating you the way that you want to be treating them. Right. So if you're someone who is like, I really want you to meet my friends and they're not doing that, there is an imbalance there. Like that's also a very easy way
几乎是从一种匮乏的心态出发，认为你最需要的是一段感情，而对于男性来说，他们最需要的是职业上的成功或是财务稳定。尽管我们认为情况已经发生了变化，但在我们的成长方式中，这种观念仍然非常隐性。在我们周围看到的世界中，它也非常隐性。所以我觉得这就是为什么男性更能做出那种判断。另外，我太喜欢这一点了，他竟然把你介绍给他的朋友。我总是说，他们应该以你希望被对待的方式来对待你。对吧。所以如果你是一个这样的人：我真的很想让你见我的朋友，而他们却没有这样做，那这里面就存在失衡。这也是一种非常简单的方式，
to see it. Yeah. I mean, I hadn't really thought too deeply into it. And like I remember when I first, you know, started hanging out with him. He was just so inclusive. Like he just made me feel wanted and appreciated and he wanted to show me off. That was it. It was like he wanted to put me on a pedestal and say, look at her. This is the person I'm with. And I had never had that before. I had never really had someone that was so proud to be next to me. And I think that's what it taught me is like there are people out there that will be so proud to show you off and be next to you and be like, this is the person I'm with. Like I'm so proud to be dating them. And I always felt that sense. of like I was proud to be dating him also.
能看清这一点。嗯。我的意思是，我之前并没有对它进行过深入的思考。就像我记得当我刚开始，你知道，和他开始交往的时候。他真的非常包容。他就是让我觉得自己是被渴望的、被欣赏的，而且他想向别人炫耀我。就是这样。就好像他想把我放在基座上说，看看她。这就是我在一起的人。我以前从来没有过这种体验。我从来没有真正遇到过一个人，能这么自豪地站在我身边。我觉得这教给我的一点是，这个世界上确实有人会非常自豪地向别人炫耀你，站在你身边，然后说，这就是我在一起的人。就像我能和他约会感到无比自豪。我一直都有这种感觉，
You know, I was like a mutual exchange of like we were both proud to be each other's partners. And I think that's such a good feeling because you're like, I love the qualities that you have and I'm not embarrassed to be out in public with you because there's been people that have treated me badly. And I'm like, if I run into someone I know and they know what's going on with this situation. It's like that makes me look bad because I'm like tolerating someone that, you know, won't
就好像我也为能跟他约会感到自豪。我觉得这真是一种极好的感觉，因为你会想，我喜欢你身上的这些品质，而且我跟你一起走在公众场合一点也不觉得尴尬，因为以前有人那样糟糕地对待过我。然后我会想，如果我碰到认识的人，而他们又了解这种状况。那就让我显得很糟糕，因为我觉得自己在容忍一个，你知道的，
commit to me or whatever. And my friends know if they see me out, they're going to shit on me for being with this person, you know? But with him, I remember I was like, I want the people in my life to know how amazing he is. And I think he, you know, he felt the same way about me. So it ended up being a really good relationship. But it also set the standards. So now it's like, that's what I want times 100. Like if I'm going to get married to someone, my husband better be shouting my name from the rooftops in New York City. Yeah. You know, bare minimum. You know, that's seen in friends where Monica gets engaged. and she's like, I'm engaged.
不肯给我承诺的人，诸如此类。我的朋友如果在外头看到我，肯定会因为我和这种人在一起而狠狠吐槽我，你知道吗？但跟他在一起时，我记得我当时想，我希望我生命中的人都能知道他是多么优秀。而且我觉得他，你知道的，对我也有同样的感受。所以最后这是一段非常美好的感情。但它也设定了标准。所以现在的情况是，这就是我想要的，而且要乘以100倍。如果我要和某人结婚，我的老公最好能在纽约街头大声喊出我的名字。对。你知道的，最低标准。你知道老友记里莫妮卡订婚的那一幕吗？
I want my husband to be doing that, please, and thank you. Like, you are the prize. So I feel like if that's like the gold standard, our tendency to get attached too quickly, we've already identified as not helping us in this. Because it's not, A, allowing you to see, yeah, you're not seeing things clearly. Sometimes it ends up sabotaging the relationship
她大喊着，我订婚啦！我希望我的老公也能那样做，谢谢配合。就像，你才是那个大奖。所以我觉得如果这就是黄金标准的话，我们过快投入感情的倾向，我们已经认定这对我们毫无帮助。因为，A，它不允许你去看清，对吧，你根本没有看清状况。有时它最终反而会破坏这段感情，
where you, like, put undue pressure, not on the other person, but on you as a couple, you as a pair way too early before like it's ready to hold that kind of responsibility. So what are some of the ways that we can kind of slow down the attachment process, take things slowly, take our time and really listen to our gut instinct? Well, I think it comes down to what we were talking about earlier is really grounding yourself and being in your own frame and knowing that, you know, you should not be. settling just because you're alone. And that's a big thing that a lot of people, as you just said,
让你，比如，施加不必要的压力，不是给对方，而是作为伴侣的你们俩，在还没准备好承担这种责任之前，过早地把这种压力压在你们身上。那么，我们有哪些方法可以稍微放慢依恋的过程，慢慢来，花点时间，并且真正倾听我们的直觉呢？嗯，我觉得这归结到我们刚才谈论的内容，那就是真正让自己脚踏实地，保持自己的节奏，并且知道，你知道的，你不应该因为自己孤单就将就。这是一个很大的问题，很多人，正如你刚才所说，
that really blew my mind earlier. The point you made about how men have the societal, they don't have the societal pressure that women do to settle because they're, you know, it's like the clock is ticking for women. That's like a whole thing that I guess we see advertised everywhere nowadays. And I think there's so much truth to that. And I think just putting everything into perspective and understanding that it's so much worse to rush and deep dive into someone that's not good for you and latch onto someone that's not good for you and then get attached to something that's not going anywhere. It's so much worse in the long term. And really thinking about it from like pulling yourself out of it and looking like from a bird's eye view in a way and just saying, okay, like, how is this going to help me in the long term?
刚才真的让我大开眼界。你提到的关于男性拥有社会压力，他们没有女性那种为了安定下来而不得不将就的社会压力，因为她们，你知道的，就好像女人的生物钟在倒计时。我猜这就像是我们现在到处都能看到的广告宣传一样。我觉得这其中包含着太多的真理。而且我觉得只要把一切都放在正确的视角下去看待，就会明白，盲目冲动并一头扎进一个不适合你的人怀里，依恋一个不适合你的人，然后跟一个毫无结果的人产生羁绊，这种后果从长远来看要糟糕得多。真正从长远角度去思考，把自己抽离出来，从某种意义上讲，像开上帝视角一样去看待它，然后对自己说，好吧，这从长远来看对我有何帮助？
if you don't think it is and you think it's not going to go anywhere, it's better to wait and it's better to focus on yourself and direct all that energy inwards. And I think like ways I've done that is, you know, I mean, this might sound cliche. But actually, though, I meditate every single day. And I tell myself self-love affirmations almost every single day. And I'm very big on self-concept because your self-concept plays into everything. And it especially plays into your relationships. and people mirror to you where you're at in your life, right? And people mirror to you how you feel about yourself. And I think unpacking those feelings of insecurity that you have when you're latched
如果你认为没有，而且觉得这段感情不会有什么结果，那最好还是等待，最好专注于自我，把所有的能量都向内回收。我觉得我做到这一点的方法是，你知道，我的意思是，这听起来可能有点老生常谈。但事实上，我确实每天都在冥想。我几乎每天都会对自己说自我接纳的肯定语。而且我非常注重自我概念，因为自我概念会影响一切。它尤其会影响你的感情。而人们会像镜子一样向你反映出你目前的人生状态，对吧？人们会像镜子一样反映出你对自己的感觉。我觉得去解开心结，去处理当你依恋一个
onto someone that isn't good for you and kind of healing that is the step you need to take in order to not get attached and actually meet the right person. And that's something I'm working through right now because I still have my own healing to do too. like I'm looking for someone that's going to be the long term like the end game and I still have stuff that I'm healing which is like settling just because you know someone treats you nice temporarily and takes you to dinner like that's not a reason why you should latch on to them that's that is the bare minimum that's it doesn't mean that that's your soulmate right like but you could have
不适合你的人时所产生的不安全感，并治愈这种心理，这就是你需要采取的步骤，这样才不会盲目依恋，才能真正遇到对的人。这也是我目前正在努力克服的事情，因为我自己也有需要疗愈的地方。比如我在寻找那个能陪我走到最后、修成正果的人，而我身上依然有些东西需要疗愈，那就是——仅仅因为你知道某人暂时对你很好、带你去吃晚饭就选择将就，这绝对不是你该依恋他们的理由，那是最低标准，仅此而已。这并不意味着那就是你的灵魂伴侣，对吧？但当你单身了一段时间后，你可能会
these blinders on when you're alone for a while which I under I, I, empathize, you know, I empathize when people are like, alone for a long time. You kind of have these, like, delusional goggles on sometimes. And you got to, you got to rip the goggles off. It's because you're coming at it, I think, from like a, like a scarcity mindset, where you're like, wow, I'd better grab, like, it's kind of like when everyone, when you feel like everyone else has something that you want, you're just going to grab, like, the first thing that you see, because it's going to fulfill at least the sense that you have it. I also think that when you talk about like meditating and positive affirmations,
戴上有色眼镜。我理解，我理解，你知道的，当人们单身很长时间时。有时你确实会戴着某种妄想滤镜。你必须，你必须把这副滤镜撕下来。这是因为你带着一种，我觉得，类似于 scarcity mindset（匮乏心态）的心态，你会觉得，哇，我最好赶快抓住，这就好像当每个人，当你觉得别人都拥有你想要的东西时，你就会随手抓住你看到的第一个东西，因为它至少能满足你“拥有它”的感觉。我也觉得当你谈到冥想和积极的肯定语时，
positive affirmations work. There is so much psychology behind it. The way you speak to yourself impacts your behavior and impacts the kind of the, I hate the word vibe because it sounds so like unscientific. But kind of like the energy that you give off. Ever since I started really making a habit of changing my inner dialogue and saying, you know, I am the best person, this, like, I'm the best person that anyone's ever going to meet. I know it might sound a little, not narcissistic, but it sounds like full of yourself.
积极的肯定语确实管用。这背后有太多的心理学依据。你跟自己说话的方式会影响你的行为，并影响那种，我讨厌“vibe（氛围）”这个词，因为它听起来太不科学了。但有点像你散发出的那种能量。自从我真正养成了改变内心独白的习惯，对自己说，“我是最棒的人，这个，我是任何人都会遇到的最棒的人。”我知道这听起来可能有点，不是自恋，但听起来像是自我感觉良好。
No. It's just, it's good, you know, it's good to feel like the best person in the room. Why wouldn't you want to feel like the best person in the room? Like, it doesn't mean that necessarily objectively, like maybe other people wouldn't agree with that, but it doesn't matter, you know? It matters how you feel about yourself. And that's why I always, I started telling myself these things. Like, I'm the most amazing person.
不。这只是，这很好，你知道的，觉得自己是房间里最优秀的人感觉很好。你为什么不想觉得自己是房间里最优秀的人呢？这并不一定意味着在客观上，也许其他人不同意这一点，但这没关系，你知道吗？重要的是你对自己的感觉。这就是为什么我总是，我开始对自己说这些话。比如，我是最了不起的人。
I'm so successful. I'm so beautiful. I'm so confident. These things are okay to feel about yourself. You know? Like, why shouldn't everyone feel good about themselves? So I, yeah, I do really agree with that. The whole psychology behind affirmations. I've seen massive changes in my life ever since I started. Also, it's interesting because I think a lot of people get concerned that that kind of behavior is like narcissistic. The thing is when you are in a world that is constantly trying to break down, your sense of self-concept or your sense of self-esteem, you kind of need an exaggerated practice like that, or you need to speak to yourself in an exaggerated, highly positive way to counteract that negativity in order to reach a balance. Like, I do genuinely believe it,
我太成功了。我太漂亮了。我太自信了。对自己有这种感觉是完全没问题的。你知道吗？为什么每个人不都应该对自己的感觉良好呢？所以，是的，我真的很赞同这一点。肯定语背后的心理学原理。自从我开始这样做以来，我的生活发生了巨大的变化。还有，这很有趣，因为我觉得很多人会担心这种行为有点像自恋。问题在于，当你身处一个不断试图摧毁你的自我概念或自尊心的世界时，你某种程度上确实需要这种夸张的练习，或者你需要以一种夸张、高度积极的方式对自己说话，来抵消这种负面影响，从而达到平衡。真的，我由衷地相信这一点，
and affirmations are an amazing way to do that. Set a behavioral intention as well. Be like, I'm not going to settle for this. I'm not going to settle for and write a list. And also, write a list of what you truly want and when you meet someone actually honestly evaluate them against those against you know those them those non-negotiables it's a way to make sure that when it comes to situations of the heart when it comes to situations that are very emotional like attachment you are maintaining like your rational edge you are maintaining like a logical steady head when it comes to these situations, especially if you know that you are someone who gets maybe carried away. And I think also make sure that you sustain your emotional independence.
而肯定语就是做到这一点的绝佳方法。同时也设定行为上的意图。对自己说：我绝不将就。我绝不接受……并列一张清单。此外，列一张你真正想要的清单，当你遇到某人时，对照这份清单、对照那些“不可妥协的底线”诚实地评估他们。这是一种确保在面对心动时刻、面对像依恋这样充满情绪的时刻时，你能保持理智的边缘，你能保持逻辑清晰、头脑冷静，尤其当你深知自己可能是那种容易冲昏头脑的人的时候。我认为还要确保维持你的情感独立。
So often I used to find that I would be entirely reliant on someone else's reactions and behavior and their receptiveness to me to determine my mood. I definitely do that. Oh yeah. No, that's so common. you know when if someone doesn't react the way you expect them to or someone doesn't text you back right away or something where you just are kind of accept like you're kind of expecting a certain response if you don't get that exact response or someone's not treating you the right way it's so easy to emotionally react to that and be like oh my whole day's ruined you know but um yeah i it's very relatable but it's also like tying back into self concept once you have such a strong sense of self those things don't affect you anymore. You know, I feel like that it's happened less and less to me. Like I get less negative reactions from people now that I'm more grounded, which is an amazing thing because I think a lot of the time I was always waiting on someone's validation
我以前经常发现，我完全依赖于别人的反应、行为以及他们对我的接受程度来决定我的心情。我以前绝对会这样。哦，对。不，这太常见了。你知道的，如果别人的反应不如你预期，或者有人没有立刻回你信息，或者诸如此类的事情，你本来期待某种特定的回应，如果没有得到那种确切的回应，或者别人没有以正确的方式对待你，你就会非常容易对此做出情绪化的反应，并觉得：哦，我一整天都毁了，你知道吗？但是，嗯，是的，这非常有共鸣，但这也回到了自我概念上——一旦你拥有了如此强大的自我意识，这些事情就再也无法影响你了。你知道，我觉得这种情况发生在我身上的次数越来越少。当我变得越来越沉稳时，我从别人那里受到的负面反应也越来越少，这是一件了不起的事，因为我觉得在很长一段时间里，我总是在等待别人的验证——
of the things they said to me or how they said it or the way they phrased it in order to make me feel like, oh, I'm doing a good job. You know what I mean? And it's like you don't need that. Like you don't, this person, unless they prove it to you means nothing. Like that was a real mindset shift. where I was like, you do not deserve to be in my life until you prove that you want to be there. And then we can talk.
等待他们对我说的话，他们说话的方式，或者他们措辞的方式，来让我觉得自己，哦，我做得很好。你知道我的意思吗？这就好像你根本不需要那个。就像你不需要，这个人除非向你证明，否则他什么都不是。这真是一个思维模式的转变。当时我想：你不配进入我的生活，除非你证明了你渴望呆在这里。然后我们再谈。
Like, then we can see what happens. So I think that's really important. It also prevents you from fantasy bonding when you, like, recognize that your emotional independence means a lot more than your connection to that person. Your sense of, like, just emotional wellness as well. You said something on your show the other day that was like, if this person is making you feel like ill or sick to your stomach, like that is not a good sign. Like if they am at any point making you feel like it's not a good sign. Like you don't have like IBS.
然后我们再看情况发展。所以我觉得这真的很重要。当你认识到你的情感独立性远比你与那个人的连接更重要时，它还能防止你陷入幻想羁绊。你对情感健康本身的感受也是如此。你前几天在节目里说过一句话，大意是：如果这个人让你感到恶心或胃部不适——这绝对不是一个好兆头。如果在任何时候他们让你觉得，那真不是个好兆头。就像你并没有患肠易激综合征（IBS）。
You don't have like chronic like stomach pains. Like this person is like it's just bad for you. Like they're creating physical reactions in your body. So it's also something to remember. Oh yeah. For sure. I definitely have had. I've had physical reactions to people before where, like, I was physically repulsed by things that, like, happened.
你并没有那种慢性的胃痛。这个人，这纯粹是对你不利。他们正在你的身体里引发生理反应。所以这也是需要记住的一点。哦，是的。肯定的。我以前对某些人确实有过生理反应，比如，我对发生的某些事情感到生理性抗拒。
And, you know, felt actually, like, actually felt ill at times. I kept getting sinus infections when I was around this one person. Every time I would hang out with them, I got a sinus infection the next day. That's your body telling you something. And it was like, and sinuses are, I think sinuses are linked to your emotions, your emotional well-being in general, like, from a spiritual perspective. and I was doing some research on this and your body can react in crazy ways when you're around people that are not good for you
而且，你知道的，实际上觉得，有时真的觉得恶心。每当我跟某个人在一起时，我就会一直得鼻窦炎。每次跟他们待在一起，第二天我就会得鼻窦炎。那是你的身体在向你传达某种信号。而且，鼻窦炎，我觉得从精神层面来讲，鼻窦炎与你的情绪、你的整体情绪健康息息相关。我为此做了一些研究，当你身处那些对你不利的人身边时，
and that are sucking your energy dry and that's another way to know if you're attached to the wrong person. So keep that in mind. Also stress, like stress increases cortisol. It's going to make you experience, like, illness and sickness. It's going to suppress your immunity more that is, like, an important way your body is telling you
那些会榨干你能量的人，你的身体会以疯狂的方式做出反应。这也是判断你是否依恋了错误之人的另一种方法。所以请记住这一点。还有压力，压力会增加皮质醇。它会让你经历疾病和身体不适。它会进一步压制你的免疫力，这是你的身体在告诉你
that something isn't right. So I think that that is a good place to end. things with a health warning. And I really do hope that like, I really do hope that if you are someone who gets attached too quickly that this episode has helped you, that this episode has given you something to think about. You know, we're moving into the new year and we're going to move into the new year unattached and absolutely madly in love with ourselves and not with someone who doesn't deserve it. So I want to thank Liz so much again for coming on. If you do not listen to her podcast, I personally listen to it. I think it's amazing
情况不对的一种重要方式。所以我觉得用一个健康警示来作为结尾是个不错的选择。我真的真心希望，如果你是一个太快陷入依恋的人，这一集能对你有所帮助，能给你一些启发。你知道的，我们要迈向新的一年，我们要不带任何依恋、疯狂且深爱着自己地迈向新的一年，而不是爱上一个不值得的人。所以我要再次非常感谢莉斯作客节目。如果你还没有听过她的播客，我个人一直在听。我觉得它太棒了，
and it gives me a lot to think about. I'm sure it will give you a lot to think about as well. So thanks for coming on again. Thank you. Thank you. I tell everyone about your podcast also. It's amazing and I'm just grateful that I'm on again. Yeah, women supporting women, guys. That's what it's all about. As always, if you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. And if you have an episode suggestion, if you just want to get in touch, see some behind-the-scenes content. You can follow us on Instagram at that psychology podcast.
它给了我很多思考。我相信它也会给你带来很多启发。所以再次感谢你来作客。谢谢。谢谢你。我也把你的播客推荐给所有人。它真的太棒了，我很感激能再次受邀。是的，女孩支持女孩，朋友们。这才是最重要的。一如既往，如果你喜欢这一集，请随时在苹果播客、Spotify或你现在收听节目的任何平台上留下五星好评。如果你有节目建议，或者只是想与我们取得联系，查看一些幕后花絮内容。你可以在Instagram上关注我们：@thatpsychology podcast。
We will be back next week with another guest episode. So we will see you then. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to,
我们下周将带着另一期嘉宾访谈节目回归。那么我们到时见。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？欢迎收听《硬着头皮学》，我是你们最喜爱的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖姆斯。这个空间专门探讨黑男性的经历，进行那些在任何地方都无法真正安全展开的坦诚对话，而你正与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人披着一身盔甲？它向世界释放出的信号是：你可不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要去使用它，
listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor Star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test. twice Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
请在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《硬着头皮学》。2023年，《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下了一对双胞胎。但这桩怀孕事件似乎是一个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试结果两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。
Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
格雷格，一个女同性恋。迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑子彻底炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《受困之爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《受困之爱》播客。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练以及在我们这个奇特现代世界中建立韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的自己。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get. your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target.
收听《2%》。即数字的TWO%。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方。当一群女性发现她们约会过同一个惯犯骗子时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。
He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an. Heart Podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他休想就这样逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听。这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。